person somebody would q okay who is that
oh it's make forecast 46 degrees
[Laughter]
weirdest thing like take this
temperature of the room you just press
that button I don't know this yeah no
it's not god it's your fingerprint yes
sirree yeah it's eerie yeah yeah yeah
what's the difference between Siri and
Alexa but this is same concept same
concept yeah yeah I like Alexa yeah
she's cool yeah turns off the lights
there's Persian isn't it Siri like you
know like Syria no like hey there's Siri
she's Persian like that when you say it
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah oh why you
think Siri isn't a Persian name oh my
bad yeah here's some little white girl
names series yeah yeah that's true yeah
why did they name yeah man yeah prison
would I'll probably cuz we just did a
thing we talked about how Bill Cosby
what he said it wasn't me he's having an
amazing time in prison let me see that
yeah yeah why because he seems like an
addict he seemed like something to have
some problems sometimes those people
just like structure they just want to be
in a place right you know where they're
comfortable he might be getting a little
bit of sex sometimes those guys you can
get conjugal visits and get that
organized sex oh I see that maybe that's
going on I think his first week yeah I'd
like a chicken patty thrown at his face
with two foods thrown in for a bad joke
yeah yeah where was the other [ __ ] oh
my funny bone [ __ ] duck the chicken
patty yeah you've really worked in the
industry what is the work I mean the
worst is here's the worst when your
attic
it's Friday second Channel and you can
just tell they're unruly oh yeah right
you know you know there's really not
much you can do is to get through it all
right that's the worst [ __ ] feeling I
think you get those or no anymore
yeah I get that I mean that's a bad
feeling dude I like I don't like um what
are we talking about something we like
our own life what do you mean I know
Chris Sabo take the glasses off dude
it's [ __ ] sorry
oh yeah yeah yeah now you're here oh
yeah yeah that's a good time yeah what
the worst thing in happening oh they had
a mental this isn't uh where was this
one time Texas I think Austin that a
mentally challenged person started
calling me the N word from the audience
a white hood no yeah cap city huh yep
cap city right and some ones I might
ever went there we're in the little room
in the front uh-huh
and somebody just started yelling
mentally challenged person sort of
staged
Wow and what you would you say you know
I tried to convince him that you know
they had the wrong guy
right I would've got shut up [ __ ] right
because he's not yeah right so if you're
gonna play that game you're right throw
throw another [ __ ] racist thing toward
him right yeah and then it would have
got a laugh maybe oh that's true yeah I
don't know what I did I think also a lot
of people really immediately keyed in
that this guy was mentally challenged
you know yo one time my first time in
Houston I was the first time I headline
after man team window this weekend
actually would they improv yeah and it's
also a lot except for Thursday night
late are you gonna kill it that you have
you been there before never been you've
never been there oh you're gonna love it
really yeah and then say hello to the
manager he's a good friend of mine
what's his name
Raymond okay you're Eamonn are you sure
that is mentally nice not it's not no no
a lot of challenge people are given the
name Raymond when they 15 if you'll
realize that really sounds like oh
that's alright
we're from Rain Man you think from
Ronnie from Raymond or from Raymond yeah
yeah he are
he looks like a like he's a part of the
Addams Family
oh really they kind of yeah would you
like Gomer what's a know what is Gomez
Gomer it's [ __ ] dark man damn dag you
look [ __ ] tell them I said hi though
yeah Iranian you're gonna love him he's
a good doer Lee I love Texas II love
Texas but the first time I went there it
was after Matt and my eighth I was with
Matt Blake and he goes on you got a
headline because you're not making money
you got a headline mm-hmm all right how
much time to a guy do it he does 45 Wow
and I go I don't have it like I don't
have it you can make it you can do it
just take all your old bits mix it
around right I'm not [ __ ] can you did
that's like a board meeting at a Taco
Bell what we gonna have around put fire
coming up with a that Taco Bell has five
things I know they make 50,000 things
out of it you're very clever Yeah right
they take the hard shell they use the
reef I bring that adhesive when when do
you look at fried great fried brains
about that's adhesive usually on the
third day Holy's boy yeah yeah that's
grandma [ __ ] cousin it's a free whole
isn't hang me so I hang this drywall
baby yeah but uh
so I second show but dude literally the
first I didn't maybe 38 minutes
mmm and he was like nah that's not good
enough the guy it wasn't Raymond at the
time
Oh the second she was so rowdy I thought
I did 38 mmm I said good night I got off
I did 12 12 minutes and I get off the
stage
in the matter because if it goes you
gotta go back out though right I go I
don't have to so rowdy I can't I have
nothing I can't do it yeah he's like you
know rowdy - yeah it's in the crowd and
then I remember customers coming and
going how come you didn't do longer yeah
like a walk I remember it being so
[ __ ] embarrassing because when you
have a name like that's why guys like
you know Piven Jeremy Piven is now
headlining clubs you know but he's not a
I mean he's been going up around town
he's entertaining
he's very attending but imagine him
having a rowdy crowd on a second show at
a club that's packed cuz he's gonna pack
them in right be scary it'd be scary
dude it's tough it's a tough business
but they make you do it because you have
a name yeah
if you draw you know but guys like you
know Michael Rapaport of doing it and
they're like throwing them so that's why
I like Robert I see him following real
good guys he's not afraid because I
think what he's doing is he's trying to
like you know throw himself to the
wolves and he knows that that's gonna
right help him get fat better faster
yeah right uh yeah he's pretty fearless
in essence of putting himself out in the
spaces because yeah I mean he's getting
in lineups you know that are pretty wild
pretty heavy line I mean the best in the
world I think yeah I mean I've seen him
in line of following dudes that are
[ __ ] monsters yeah and he goes up
there and he does it you know and he's
not eating and he's doing good you know
I'm he's not he could be better yeah him
in a stage in 20 years yeah yeah so I
just get him back into it and the shop
did that too yeah job you know you know
obviously he got into a knee he got fast
good pretty fast I think
yeah he's allowed me lucky those guys
are hard workers you know that's one
thing about it is I guess it's a lot of
just repetition yeah yeah like with
anything you do it enough you can do it
yeah so and then like I think the
ability to you know start to really do
it as well as you can will can develop
over to over time you know yeah Haven
one thing that Piven has is he's very
entertaining like he will whole like you
were he's very like he can tell a story
he's a good storyteller so you get it
you're in there with him
you know Rappaport is extremely
confident and loud and like you know see
you go on these journeys with him he's
really you know he's like six three or
sake force you you know he's that
larger-than-life person I see you go on
these journeys with ya
so they have a lot of natural gifts that
uh that'll definitely help them on the
stage yeah it's it's an interesting
phenomenon because I remember the
opposite I remember no obviously when
you start off no one knows you know you
have no connection to anything do
mentally handicapped people thought I
was black when I said yeah I mean you
sent up at these open mics right and you
do it no one's laughs yeah knows you and
then if you eat it you get offstage no
one consoles you because you don't know
anybody
oh dude there was a fire I went to one
time there was a fire right it was that
uh it was this place yes I'm probably
Mexican restaurant herself right I'm
someplace you know or could have been
like some you know I don't know I'm just
so they had a [ __ ] fire and then the
guys like well don't leave were the only
people there he's like don't leave we'll
do it you know right after the yeah you
know fire me once shame on you yeah I
saw and people you can you can rip up
and see all you want people do and I
have my feelings about him you know I'm
you know I she's done good things for me
he's behaved in three drinks for either
in weird way